[Music]
but well first of all we have the writer
director AR Aristotle here and Lizzie
the producer if you didn't already
know um congratulations on all the
success that you've had so far this year
with your film um and if you didn't
already know this film was won best
cinematography at South by Southwest
earlier this year which is
understandable because it's uh beautiful
the way that it's shot um and I'd love
to talk about that in a minute uh but
maybe we could talk a little bit first
about um I'd love to hear just a little
more about both of your backgrounds um
and kind of what you've done before this
film that got you
here okay um
wow background uh I produced a couple
movies before this one um but I like
started off as a film school kid I went
to NYU a very unique Journey uh but um I
think like after school I just kind of
like did anything anyone would let me do
commercials music videos short films I
also like crewed on larger feature films
until I like felt like I got to a point
where I could really push the projects
that I was separating along and then um
it's been a blur of like joy and Trauma
and all the things in between um since
then and getting to make this movie with
Aristotle was such a rewarding point and
experience for me in my life that's
far yeah well first I want to thank y
all for coming um yeah I started off you
know I'm an artist first in foremost so
I've experimented a lot of mediums but
did some music videos and some
commercials I made some short films
before this um and yeah I've
experimented with photography all
different types of Storytelling and
really just like to make art that makes
people think and talk and to me the
movie isn't the art it's this dialogue
now
so beautiful and I forgot to mention
well because the reason why I'm here
tonight and doing the Q&A is because
Lizzie is a fellow a film independent
fellow um and I'm here instead of one of
a member of our programming team during
the Q&A because it's our 30th
anniversary of the film independent
artist development programs it's
exciting uh so our project involved
program has been going now for 30 years
so if there's any filmmakers out there
that you don't already know about the
programs um I'm happy to talk to you
more about the programs later but Lizzie
is a Alum both from The Producers lab
and FasTrack I believe and and you won
the producers award two years ago at the
Indie Spirit Awards which is amazing
that's
my yeah so film independent is also
especially proud of Lizzy and all the
work that Lizzie's been doing in the
indie film scene so nice I'm very
appreciative of film independent I feel
like you guys really came in at a very
like early and pivotal point for me and
provided a lot of like gaps in my
knowledge and just support that I think
like I would have had a very different
experience if I like hadn't had that
community that film independent brought
so so nice to like show moving here and
just you guys yeah well we're we're very
proud of this film and and all the work
that all our fellows do um so Aristotle
I read that this was a short film first
or perhaps you made a teaser version
first uh or proof of concept um I'd love
to hear more about kind of the Genesis
of this film and the process you've been
in the steps you've taken to get to the
Future yeah um so this started off as a
short that I made in 2018 and um you
know I was just really inspired by
writing something positive about my
community the community of the Bronx and
the people that inhabit it and um you
know it's rare that on the big screen we
get to see our faces depicted in
positive lights without so many negative
stereotypes and I was really just
excited to tell a story that played in
that space and then thankfully uh An
Angel by the name of Elise who's sitting
here from the Sundance Labs convinced me
that I could turn this short into a
feature even before I did um I tried to
quit I was like I I can't do this I'm
not talented enough and thankfully uh
because of Elise and everyone else at
Sundance they helped give me that
confidence and helped me turn it into
the future y saw today wow that's
amazing
yeah um and so did you have to kind of I
imagine you had to expand what the story
was um of what the original idea was or
did you always have that full story in
mind when you were making the short no
when I was making the short my focus was
The Next Step at least for me was trying
to turn it into a play um you know I
really want to make Broadway accessible
to Inner City youth but not only make it
accessible but make it so they feel when
they're in the building and that was
really where my heart was and then I got
this insane email from aise which kind
of like changed my whole Focus um but
yeah I mean all all I had was the
robbery itself on the platform and and a
little bit of the dino conversation um
so everything before and after that was
through through the labs oh wow that's
quite an expansion yes that it was very
cool and Lizzie when did you get in
involved and and why did you get
involved um I actually I came in sort of
at a later period on this project than I
usually do I'm usually sort of their
like the first one along with the writer
director but Aristotle had done a lot of
work on this movie there um were other
producers who were also around and on
board and um Jamie Fox's company Foxhole
I was very friendly with one of their
Executives and they called me originally
just to be like how do you make a movie
at this budget in New York and not get
like flipped by the unions and like have
your whole life go up in flames and um I
was like I can do that um and then I
read the script and I thought it was so
great and I thought um Aristotle's
previous work was really strong and I
especially connected to that scene with
um Kadir and Gloria in the dark room
they're talking about sort of like uh
the difference between making authentic
art and like sustaining yourself in a
capitalist system with that art how do
you tow that line and I was like it'd be
really cool to play that for a room full
of film festival people because I'm like
we should all ask ourselves that
question and why we're here um but um
yeah and we just like met like the when
we our first meeting I think we sat for
like two or three hours and just like
really vibed and it was really clear we
wanted to make the same movie and um and
yeah and the rest is sort of history but
um but I just like I just really fell in
love with these characters and with
Aristotle and and the whole project yeah
yeah so then um so when when was that
that you got involved that was in okay
this is 2023 we job in 2022 that was
like the beginning of 2022 then yeah it
was like quick like not that long before
production like we did like a little bit
of like scripts and a lot of like
creative convers ation yeah but um
really like came on to to like help
bring together the like and assanti was
attached like there are some pretty big
pieces that Aristotle already put in
place but really just came out to like
bring it all together um and just make
sure that the movie was protected in aot
was protected in a way that would allow
us to do the best thing possible yeah
gotcha wonderful um so I'd love to chat
a bit about the
cinematography um because you were
honored for that especially and that
definitely stood out to me immediately
you know you start off with such a bold
move with having him float and you know
I think I'd love to just hear some more
about what your thought process was
behind developing that cinematic
language with your DP and yeah just some
anything you feel like sharing about
what went into all those all those
thoughts yeah I mean um as someone who
comes from commercial and videos I was
kind of trained to stare at a monitor
all day you know and I think that's like
the biggest take away from the lap from
the Sundance Labs was like really my job
as a director is to protect the story
and to craft
performances um and to cultivate a set
where the actors feel like they're
performing for me and not for the camera
you know um so in that inspiration I
really wanted to
shoot black and brown faces the way oh
Hollywood did you know and more
intentional and I think it was a
combination of uh you know limitation
Fosters creativity we didn't have a lot
of time to explore so I needed to be
very intentional about my grammar and
what I wanted to say with the lens um
but it also helped us create
confinements that enhance the themes of
the film you know so you'll notice like
at the beginning of the film there's way
more saturation there's way more vibrant
bold colors because we're being immersed
in a world that Kadir is being immersed
in but then when he builds his report
with Le colors get desaturated and
Things become a little bit more familiar
and comforting that's all intentional
you know in the First Act there's a very
shallow depth of field and as Kadir
finds more of himself and you know comes
to terms with his internal conflict then
that depth of field becomes more more
flat you know so um you know I was just
intentional in the sense of like I don't
want to spray and prey I don't want to
shoot a master and over and over in a
closeup and hope I could figure it out
in the edit you know if I got that
Medium I really only had the time for
that Medium you know and I think um um
you know it helped in creating rules and
themes that helped the emotional Arc of
the story yeah I think like you're also
so good about walking for camera cuz
like what allows for a lot of these
composed shots is that like Aristotle
really need knew where to place his
actors and how to like play the drama
within a frame whereas I feel like I've
had other experiences with directors
where they sort of like block everyone
all over the room and you end up with
like a camera running around trying to
follow and cover everybody and this was
really like the opposite of that like
things it was like you like would really
find a frame and compose everyone inside
of that space which I think was very
profound yeah I think you know the goal
is to work really hard to create a space
where
everything in the frame is meticulous
and intentional and have the time and
the resources and the support to create
that sort of film making and even though
this might have not been that for every
scene I tried my best to find areas to
choose those battles yeah well it it
felt to me I was actually thinking as I
was watching some of the scenes and when
you we you were saying outside that you
shot this in 20 days which is very fast
um with the amount of locations you seem
to have as well location yes um and but
I felt in the your coverage everything
did feel super intentional and you often
have these beautiful wides that or there
was one shot I think when you were in
the hospital that suddenly you were
completely outside of the building
looking in um and that kind of thing
usually takes time to to get so yeah
having it it makes sense of you know
Lizzy's comment about being really
intentional and kind of knowing how to
use the camera to tell your story so
that you can use your time well um I
think shows and there's a lot of shots
in there there's just a lot of shots it
wasn't
enough yeah and and the the it's a very
bold move to make your main character
kind of float at the beginning um and
you know later we have we see more like
dream sequences but the floating thing
feels to me a little different the way
we start off than the rest of it and
sets a tone that's like okay we're going
on a very unique Journey here and this
is something we haven't quite seen
before um can you talk a little more
about that choice in particular yeah I
just think that whenever you make a
movie that is pro you know predominantly
black and black and brown faces it's
hip-hop it's slang and Street Wear it's
very easy to put that kind of movie in a
box and I think think um you know we
were really intentional out the gate of
letting the audience know that this
isn't that you're going to get elements
of that but this isn't that and this is
an emotional story and it's not just
cool and um you know I thought that was
just a great way to let the audience
know that there there will be not only
other worldly elements that will
experience in the film but we are
perceiving this story through an
artist's eyes and even the things that
we're watching and experiencing might
not even be reality that's just the way
Kadir perceived them as an artist um so
I thought that was just an interesting
tool to use to do that to start yeah it
was very exciting a very exciting way to
start a film yeah
um what if both of you learned by
working on this film how long do you
have you want to go
no um I learned a lot about trusting my
instincts I'm not going to get too
specific but I learn about trusting
instincts um I learned how important it
is to have good partners you can really
trust and like what happens when when
you have a bad feeling about something
follow it um because when you see that
go the other way it can be very tough um
I also just like I don't know on set you
like learn lessons every even like tiny
little lessons every day you know I
think this movie kicked my ass right
it was really hard to do this in 20 days
um and you have to give a lot of
yourself you have to give a lot to other
people um so I just like I think was
constantly sort of confronted with like
new conflicts and tools I had to develop
it's a very general
answer having looked at looking at this
from a like bird's eye view now you know
right um what about you yeah you know
similar similarly um you know as is it's
easy to have impostor syndrome and even
from being at the labs I felt impostor
syndrome you know I come from a world
where I watch rappers throw money in the
air and try to shoot that in slow motion
and the focus you know and uh uh to go
to narrative film making where all of my
contemporaries are just these amazing
artists I was just always felt this
pressure so I think for me the biggest
lesson is I can do this you know and
it'll take a lot of sacrifice and it'll
take a lot of hard work and focus but I
believe it's my purpose this and um you
know if this is my first film then
life's all right yeah it's a very strong
first film yeah
um I'm curious to hear a little more
about the title um and also the choice
to make the it's a fictional Metro stop
just yeah anything you want to share
about that um I just thought it was a
cool title and I grew up on story yeah
so it just made sense it killed it
checked a few boxes yeah yeah in my life
yeah ex it yeah
um can we talk a little about casting
and um your two leads and just the
process of casting them and and why you
you cast them yeah I think 90% of a
director's job is casting and locations
it does so much of of the heavy lifting
For You especially on a movie like this
where when you arrive on the day you
have to start shooting you know um so
you know being able to work with this
cast um specifically Assan and Louis
even if this was my fifth film I would
have been very lucky but the fact that I
had this experience on my first film is
um a blessing to say the least cuz you
know trust is been a theme that's been
brought up like trust is huge when you
make your first movie cuz you're so
overwhelmed you get pulled in so many
directions so to have actors that you
can collaborate with that you're like
you understand this character and the
way that I want it it to be conveyed and
I don't want to put my ego in front of
the movie but you understand my
intention so now do what you feel is
right um that's a that's a blessing to
have on a first movie and the fact that
Asanti was 20 years old and he's in
every scene of this movie other than the
midpoint sequence there two sequences
but he's in every scene and he showed up
every day and every take was usable and
just poignant and composed and at 20 I
mean if I was that composed at 20 I'd be
in a way different space in my life and
Lou is just so wise and he's done so
many different types of movies and work
with so many different types of
directors that he brings a certain um
experience to the film that I don't know
if we would have had otherwise that
provided like a a a blanket of comfort
for everyone else to know that we were
in good hands so I was really fortunate
with with the cast on this yeah we love
to say the Lou goz man's the best first
day in New York by far
by by he moves you along you're Lou
time that's great yeah I would I feel
like he often has played so many more
stereotypical type characters and it was
so great to see him just in more depth
and yeah just just a real seeing his
acting chops even more so than we
normally see so that was cool I mean as
a Puerto Rican from the Bronx like my
mom is
happy yeah he was wonderful he he
brought so much like depth and heart to
the whole thing and that was great
um what what's next for the film what
what's going to go on what's going to
happen next for this film we're opening
in LA this weekend tell your
friends follow our Instagram we run it
so we'll personally know it
follow um and then we're like opening in
a bunch of cities all over the us and
we're continuing to book theaters and
and we we had a really strong start in
New York which has been so important
opening weekends are like especially
important for a movie like ours that
depends on performance to stay in
theaters um so it's like uh yeah I don't
know like The Little Engine That Could
um and I think a lot of people really
like connected to and and loved this
movie and there's been some pretty like
emotional uh moments for us with with a
lot of people so it's I think that's
like for us one of the most important
things is to just make a movie the
people can really connect to and I think
you really did that oh seemed did I out
anything anything next that you want to
that you want to mention no okay I guess
on a similar note um yeah what do you
want what do you audiences take away
from watching your film and yeah what
yeah just perspective you know hopefully
when you look at graffiti Your Instinct
isn't it's just vandalism or criminal
activity you can maybe think about it
for a second if this is some sort of
artistic expression and someone risked
their life and their freedom to express
this thing um and I hope that you know
it offers a layer of empathy so if you
see someone sleeping out on the street
maybe your initial Instinct isn't
they're just like a bum but you know you
think like what if I made all the right
decisions in life and still ended up in
this position and I hope my film can at
least offer a nugget or seat of that
kind of
empathy yeah and I think a that a little
bit of kindness can go a really long way
in someone's way um small acts of and I
think this is a pretty big act of
kindness you know are very needed in
this world especially in this moment
that is crazy yeah I mean luis's charact
I mean he's Lis in the movie too right
um he changes that boy's life like he
completely spins it into a different
direction than than he was going so
that's really profound to get to watch
on an example of that on film was really
powerful um what and what's next for
both of you if you have that too this
try to get out this and make some more
movies uh yeah I like Aristotle has a
couple movies in development that he's
working on um I've got a few movies that
desperately want to shoot um next year
so I'm I think um Sears men and big like
roll this movie out here and I think
next year we're both going to be doing
some things willing sag let us know yeah
you're like I'm Gloria I'm trying to
sell
[Music]
out um is there anything I missed that
you want to share with our audience no
just I'm so honored that y'all are here
to watch this film it's really close to
my heart it was a true labor of love
took a lot of Sacrifice from a lot of
amazing people to show yall this so I'm
just very honored that we're here right
now well thanks so much for being here
film independent and thank you all for
joining us tell your friends about the
film
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
please